Hello, and welcome to this
episode of Google Developers
Live.
I'm Sarah Maddox from the Google
Maps Developer Relations team.
In this video you will learn
how to add a place autocomplete
widget to a map created with
the Google Maps JavaScript API.
I'll also show you how
an autocompete widget can
be useful even without a
map to auto-fill an address
form for example.
Let's take a look
at it in action.
Autocomplete gives
your applications
the type ahead search behavior
of the search field on a Google
map.
Start typing something into the
address box and autocomplete
supplies predictions.
You can configure the
autocomplete widget
to return specific
types of places,
geographical places
like towns and cities,
or establishments
like pizza places,
or regions in other
geographical areas.
If no type is specified the
widget will return all types.
If you haven't already
seen our videos
on getting started with
the JavaScript API,
now is a really good
time to watch them.
Let's get started with the code.
If you've created
a map before you'll
recognize this as
the basic JavaScript
used to create a map.
Place autocomplete is part
of the Google Places library.
So our first step is to
add the Google Places
library to the JavaScript API.
There are a number
of libraries that
provide additional functionality
for the JavaScript API
and one of them is the
Google Places library.
So to add a library, include
the libraries parameter
in the JavaScript API Loader.
Here I've specified
libraries=places.
Autocompete adds a text
input element to your page
and responds with
predictions when
the user types
into the text box.
So, we need to define an HTML
input element of timed text.
And next we can set some options
for the autocomplete widget.
I've decided to use a default
area for the search conducted
by autocomplete.
To define the area, I've
created a LatLngBounds object.
It defines a
rectangle on the earth
by setting the
latitude and longitude
for the southwest corner
and for the northeast
corner of the rectangle.
The autocomplete will bias
its search to this area
but not restrict the
results to that area.
I've decided to bias
my search results
to an area in Sydney, Australia.
I've also created
the variable, which
I've called options, that
contains the bounds object.
Now, we hook up the HTML
input element as a variable
and add some magic to push
the autocomplete widget
onto the map canvas.
And finally create
the autocomplete
object, passing it,
the input element,
and the options object.
Let's take a look at the
autocomplete widget in action
again.
So one thing to note is
that by default autocomplete
will automatically determine
the user's location by looking
at their IP address and
will bias the search
results to that location.
You can turn off this
location awareness
by setting the bounds to
encompass the whole world.
Use bounds of (-90,
-180) and (90, 180.)
You can also set the
bounds to the browser's
navigated geolocation object.
And there are other
options that you
can use to customize
the autocomplete widget.
The details are all
in the documentation.
Here's a hint, you can
use the geocoding API
to find the latitude
and longitude
coordinates of the
location you have in mind.
So here's a link to the
geocoding API documentation.
OK, let's think
outside the map, how
about using autocomplete to
auto-fill an address form.
There's a really nice example
in the documentation, which
I'm just going to
show you quickly.
And you could come
along later and have
a look at the code
in more detail.
Here's my address form.
Start typing the address where
it says enter your address
and autocomplete
supplies the predictions.
When I select one
of these predicted
places the JavaScript
I have takes
the users getPlace to retrieve
the information retrieved
from the Google Places
services and puts the address
into components on the form.
Let's take a look at the
code for the address box
by scrolling down on
this documentation page.
We've supplied the
code after the sample.
So we use getPlace to
get the information
about the place
including the address
and then we take each
element of the address
and parse it and put
it into the form.
When we use a selected place
from the list information
about the place is returned
to the autocompete object
and your application can grab
that information via getPlace
and use it to populate
the fields on your form.
So as I said, you can
go to a documentation
and have a closer
look at the code
and the address form in action.
What about styling.
You can style the
autocomplete dropdown
to suit your own
branding or site design.
So let's see a simple example.
In this example I've
colored my autocomplete box
a nice varnished yellow and
styled the dropdown to match.
So that's a really simple
example of styling.
The documentation has all the
details about the CSS classes
that are available.
Let's have a look at
the CSS that I used.
I've just styled the
pac-container class
and the documentation
describes all the other classes
available.
If JavaScript isn't
your thing or if you're
working on a mobile app, have
a look at the Google Places web
service tool, what
we've been looking at
is the JavaScript library.
I hope you've enjoyed this video
from Google Developers Live.